The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So this
hour we're going
to talk about SIMD
programming with cell.
First we'll talk a
little bit about what
SIMD is and then
about the facilities
that cell and the
compiler provide
for programming with SIMD.
And then some design
considerations
that you have to keep in mind
when you're doing things.
All right so the
situation these days
is that most compute
bound applications
are running through
a large piece of data
and running the same
computations on it
over and over again,
or rather running
the same computations across all
the pieces of different data.
And very frequently
there'll be no dependence
between iterations when you're
going through this data.
So that means
there's opportunities
for you to data parallelize.
So as an example, if
we have for example,
say we're multiplying
a0 and b0 to get c0.
And suppose we want
to actually perform
this operation across all the
elements of arrays a, b and c.
So instead of multiplying
two elements or two integers
together, we're actually
going to be taking two arrays
an element-wise multiplying
each of the-- multiplying each
of the pairs
element-wise and writing
the results to a third array.
So the picture's going to
look something like this.
And you would of
course represent this
using for example, four loop.
Now what we're going to do
is instead of-- let's see,
so you can think of this as
kind of an operation that's
abstractly operating
on these entire arrays.
And we're not going
to go quite that far,
but what we're
going to do is we're
going to think of
these operations
as acting on these kind
of bundles of elements.
So we're going to bundle
our arrayed elements
into groups of four.
And then each time we're
going to take a group
and multiply with
another group using
this element-wise multiplication
and write the result
to this third bundle.
OK does that make sense?
Now the thing about
this kind of model
is that cell is going to
provide very good hardware
support for something that
looks kind of like this.
AUDIENCE: Is that
actual cell [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yes,
I'll get into this.
In fact, this is what we'll
be talking about the syntax
and meaning of
this kind of thing.
All right?
So for this kind
of thing to happen
we need the compiler to
support two different things.
First is we need to be able to
address these kind of bundles
of elements and these are
going to be called vectors.
And second we need to be
able to perform operations
on these vectors.
So cell and the XLC compiler
give us support for this.
And what they're going
to do is provide first,
registers which are
capable of holding vectors.
Now normally you
think of a register
as holding on a 32-bit
machine, one machine word
will hold a 32-bit
int, for example.
What we're going
to have on the cell
is these 128-bit
registers which are
going to be able to
hold for example four
ints right next to each other.
So we're going to be able
to take this bundle of ints
and operate it--
operate on it as a unit.
And the second
part is we're going
to have operations that act
on these vector registers.
So the cell is going to support
special assembly instructions
and it's going to be
able to interpret those
as acting on particular vectors.
But also we're going to have C++
language extensions which are
called intrinsics.
And those are going
to give us access
to these special
assembly instructions,
but not require us to be
poking around in the assembly.
All right now the
big draw of this
is that these
operations are going
to be pretty much as fast
as single operations, which
means that if we take
advantage of them
we can make our code run
say four times as fast.
OK so how do we refer to these
vectors when we're coding?
XLC is going to provide
us with these intrinsics.
And we have these
vector data types
and each one is just
going to specify
how to interpret a
consecutive group of 128-bits
as some sort of vector.
And you can have vectors
of varying element sizes
and varying number of elements.
So when you're programming
on the PPU or the SPU
you get these four different
kinds of vector data types.
You can declare things
as for example, vector
signed int, which is what
I mentioned in the example.
Which is where you have four
ints next to each other each
32-bits.
You could also
have vectors which
contains 16-bit integers
or 8-bit integers.
And you could also have
vectors of floating point--
floating point numbers.
I should mention
that all of these
signed integer types also
have unsigned equivalence.
Anyway, so you can just declare
these anywhere in your code
and use them as if they
were a C++ data type.
All right any questions?
On the SPU you also get some
additional vector data types.
One is vector signed
long-long, which is 64-bit ints
and you can fit two
of those in 128.
And you can also fit two
double precision floating
point numbers in 128-bits.
Now the compiler's actually
support these types
pretty nicely.
So not only can you declare
variables of these types
pretty much anywhere
in your code,
you can also declare pointers
to these types and arrays
of these types.
All right.
And so they look pretty
much like natural C++ types,
except that they translate
directly into these particular
types that the
hardware supports.
Now in order to manipulate
these vector data,
we're going to have
the-- we're going
to have compiler
extensions called
intrinsics, which are going to
provide access to the assembly
level features that we want.
Remember we're going to have
specific assembly instructions
that correspond to for example,
multiplying two vectors which
contain each four,
32-bit integers.
And instead of writing
out-- instead of going
into the assembly and actually
inserting that instruction
ourselves, we just use a
compiler intrinsic inside
our C++ code.
And what it does is it
provides this notation that
looks a lot like
a function call,
but the compiler
automatically translates it
into the correct
assembly instruction.
And again you
don't have to worry
about going into the
assembly and messing around
with this instruction
that's supposed
to apply to these registers.
You don't have to worry about
register allocation at all.
The compiler just figures
out the right thing for you.
And to use these in your SPU
program you're going to want
to include SPU_intrinsics.h.
Now what's a little
bit confusing
is that you're going to have
slightly different intrinsics
available on the
PPU and the SPU,
because those are actually going
to have different instruction
sets.
But anyway as an example,
you can declare two variables
of type vector
signed int and then
you can multiply them using
this intrinsic called SPU add.
All right and assign them to
a third vector signed int.
Questions?
Yep.
AUDIENCE: In what way are
they introduced if you're
on the SPU or the PPU?
Is it just-- not
entirely the same set
of operations available?
Or are there actually
semantic differences?
Could make a little header file
that masks over the differences
mostly.
PROFESSOR: There are going
to be some operations that
are only available on
one and not the other.
But in general, if
you look at the names,
if the names
correspond, and I'll
go into that in a
little bit, then they
should perform essentially
the same function.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] mostly
was the [INAUDIBLE] also
some name differences where
there really don't need to be.
For instance, if you try
to do a shift on the PPU
I believe it's a [INAUDIBLE]
SL, shift logical right,
shift logical left or
shift arithmetic right.
Sort of things you
would remember.
On the SPU it's the acronym
for rotate and mask for shift.
So R-O-T-M-A-R or
something like that.
So yes there's some differences
that don't need to be there.
PROFESSOR: OK so
to actually create
these vectors there's a
couple of different notations
you can use.
The first is, you can use this
thing which looks like a cast
to, for example,
vector signed int.
So you do vector signed
int in parentheses
and then a list of four
integers you want to fill in.
And that will create an integer
vector and assign it to a.
You can also, I
believe you can also
use that notation
with just one integer
and it will fill in that
integer in all four positions.
There's also an SPU
intrinsic called splats
that you can use to basically
copy the same integer
to all four components.
AUDIENCE: How does
it know you're not
using a comma operator?
PROFESSOR: Yeah I don't--
is that right David,
with the parentheses
in the second part?
OK.
AUDIENCE: Whatever.
AUDIENCE: Another
caveat here from someone
who's been in the trenches is
that XLC likes this notation.
GCC sometimes likes curly
brace notations instead.
PROFESSOR: So I'd
seen both of those
and I do know which to do.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK great thanks.
All right.
And after you've assigned some
of these variables in order
to get back the pieces out,
one way you can do it is to use
this union trick where you
assign or rather you allocate
something of vector signed int
and then you tell C++ that it
can find an array of
integers in the same place.
And what that will do is
pull out the components.
So if you define
this union this way,
then you get a
type called intVec.
And any time you have
an intVec you can either
do dot Vec to get at the vector
signed int, the vector data
type.
Or you can use dot
vals to-- with an array
index get at the
components of the vector.
And you could also use
this intrinsic call
SPU extract to pick out
the same components.
XLC provides a bunch of
different vector operations
that you can use.
There's integer operations,
floating point operations,
there are a permutation
and formatting operations
which you can use to shuffle
data around inside vector.
And there's also load
and store instructions.
And I believe we have a
reference linked off the course
website if you want to
figure out more about these.
I'm only going to
touch on a few of them.
OK so the arithmetic and
logical operations like I said,
most of these are the same
between the PPU and the SPU.
There's some that are
named slightly differently
and some that are not
available on the PPU.
So these are all things you
would expect, add, subtract.
Madd is multiply and
then add with three--
with three arguments.
Multiply, re is for reciprocal.
You can also do
bit-wise and, or xor
and I believe there are other
logical operations there too.
Now the thing is
you have to worry
about which PPU or SPU
instruction you're using.
But you usually don't have
to worry about selecting
the right vector type.
The compiler should figure out
which vector types you're using
and substitute the
appropriate assembly
instruction that produces a
result of the same vector type.
So all these operations
are what we call generic.
And they stand in for all
the specific instructions,
which are-- which only apply
to a single vector type.
Does that make sense?
OK so one handy thing is
a permutation operation.
And this allows you to rearrange
the bytes inside a vector
or two vectors arbitrarily.
And so the syntax
is SPU shuffle a,
b which are your source
vectors and pattern which
tells you how to shuffle them.
And pattern is going
to be interpreted
as a vector of 16-bytes.
And each byte is
going to tell you--
each byte is going to tell
the compiler how to pick out
one of these bytes
in the result.
And how the byte is
interpreted is the low,
the low four bits
are going to specify
which position the source
is going to come from.
And the fourth byte is going
to specify whether you're
going to pull from a or b.
So as an example,
here's the pattern VC
and if you look at the
second byte which is
one, which is one, four in hex.
Then that means the
destination register
is going to contain the fourth
byte or the fourth byte of b,
all right.
So four means select the element
numbered four and one means
select from b.
Does that make sense?
And this is very versatile
by putting in the right,
by putting in the right
pattern vector you can arrange
for all these bytes to be
shuffled around however
you want.
AUDIENCE: The pattern is
a constant [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Pardon?
AUDIENCE: The
pattern is a constant
in intermediate parameter.
PROFESSOR: You can fill in
the parameter at run time
if that's what you're asking.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK, also useful
are these rotation operations
which will let you
shift your vector left
or right by some amount.
Now one thing to be aware
of is that on the SPU
you only have these
128-bit registers.
So on the PPU you have
different registers
which are suitable for
holding different types.
For example, there's word-sized
registers for holding ints
and PPU also has these
128-bit registers.
But the SPU has nothing else.
So that means whenever you're
using scalar types on the SPU
they're all going to be
using these large registers.
No matter what the size of
the scalar you're using.
And depending on the
size of the scalar
you're using it's going to
go in a particular position
inside this wide register.
It's called a quadword
register, because it's 16-bytes.
Now the thing to
watch out for is
that whenever you load
something from memory
into-- whenever you load
a scalar from memory
into one of these
registers, there's
going to have to be a little
extra processing done in order
to shift-- in order
to possibly shift
the scalar into the right
place inside this register.
And furthermore, the
hardware is always
going to want to grab one of
these quadwords all at a time.
So loading a scalar
is not going to be
any cheaper than loading one
of these quadword registers.
So one possible
you're going to want
to load an entire quadword
register at a time.
And if you just
need a part of it,
then you can figure
that out later.
But you might as well
get the whole thing.
Questions?
AUDIENCE: So when you--
just a scalar question.
So when you load a
scalar value that's
not aligned-- it's not aligned
with the preferred position is
that-- is there overhead
associated with that?
PROFESSOR: I'm not
sure how much overhead
is associated with that.
Pardon?
Oh do you know?
AUDIENCE: Well, unlike
scalar it's [INAUDIBLE],
it can only load on
16-byte boundaries.
So it's going to load the-- load
something that includes that
and that's going to have to
shift to the another position.
PROFESSOR: So do
unaligned-- when
it has to shift
the scalar around,
does that actually
take longer than
went in-- when it's natural?
AUDIENCE: I don't know if
it's-- well what you can do,
you can set some
flags in XLC that say,
align all of my
scalars correctly.
And we'll waste 4x overhead.
It'll even say align my array,
have my elements so that I
can have the scalar array
at the back-- I can load
and it will waste the overhead's
that everything in the array
is [INAUDIBLE].
So you can have the
compiler trade off
space versus time for
you off two switches.
PROFESSOR: I see.
OK so we're going to want to
look at the sim application
from recitation two.
And we want to adapt that to
make use of SIMD data types
and intrinsics.
So what we've done is,
remember we had these x, y, z
coordinates that we
were manipulating.
What we're going to do is
we're going to pad each one.
It was three words
before and we're
going to pad each one so
that it fills a quadword.
And so for each
quadword of course
the first three words are going
to correspond to the x, y, z
components.
And we can grab those
out using SPU extract
or some other intrinsics.
Now when we're
doing manipulations
with these components
for example,
we wanted to find
the displacement
between two locations.
And that's just subtracting
two of these coordinates.
So we can do that subtraction
which before required three
floating point subtractions.
We can replace that with
a single SIMD instruction.
Does that make sense?
OK so all this-- most of
this has already been done
and we're providing most
of the implementation
of this SIMD version of sim.
And what we want you to do
is download this, download
the tarball for this
recitation and then go in there
and what we want you to do
is fill in one of the blanks.
All right.
So there's just
one function here
that's been left unimplemented.
And to see if you
know what's going on,
see if you can fill in the
implementation for this.
Any questions?
So this question-- this
function you want to implement
is basically going to
take a vector float
and if that float
contains a, b, c and d
you want to return
a-- you want to return
a vector which each
of whose elements
is a plus b plus c plus d.
Questions?
AUDIENCE: What
directory under the--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So we're going
to go into sim a list.
AUDIENCE: But we can stay
around afterwards and help
you figure out what's going on.
PROFESSOR: OK so here's
one implementation.
Basically we're going to just
declare another vector float
and that vector
float we're going
to-- that's basically we're
just going to do these swaps.
So notice in this
one we're swapping
the first and second--
we're swapping
the first and second words.
So that means down
here we're going
to want to carry bits four,
five, six, seven and then--
or bytes four, five, six, seven
first and then bytes 0, 1, 2,
3.
And then over here we want
bytes 12, 13, 14, 15 and then
8, 9, 10, 11.
Everyone see what's going
on for the first shuffle?
And then we're going to just
add that to our original vector
to get this.
And we can do that
again, this time now
we just want to swap
these two halves.
So the shuffle pattern is going
to be 8, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14,
15 followed by 0,
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7.
Make sense?
OK so the way we translated the
program we just used into SIMD
was we used a struct of arrays.
Basically each of
these structs that we
had from our previous
implementation
just carried over and we just
put all those into an array.
So the structs were
right next to each other.
Alternatively we could
have laid out the,
laid out the data in
memory in a different way
and this is called an
array of structs layout.
Instead what we can do is
put all the like fields
next to each other so
that we have, for example,
an array of all the
x components, then
y components, then
an array of all
the z components.
And when you reorder
the data this way
you get different ways
you can use to process it.
So for example,
now each quadword
instead of containing the
data for a single point
is going to contain the data
for the same component of four
consecutive points.
Everyone see that?
And actually we can
implement the algorithm
from before in this new layout.
But we have to be a little
bit more clever in how we're
putting together the elements.
Before we were able
to just subtract
each-- subtract or multiply
the quadwords with each other,
because those would just
correspond to for example,
subtracting the
coordinates of two points.
Now this time we have to do some
additional computation in order
to put all the pieces together.
The trick behind this structure
of arrays implementation
which I'll just gloss
over is, if we're
storing state for
eight objects then
we're going to need-- eight
objects hold the-- hold 24.
Rather for each object we need
the position and the velocity.
And for each of those
we have x, y and z.
So that means to store
state for each object,
for eight objects we need
8 times 6 is 48 words.
And so we can put
those in 12 quadwords
if we pack them right.
And when we do SIMD
operations on these quadwords
that we pull out, we can
get four pair interactions.
So suppose this is a
quadword and it's contained--
and it contains
data corresponding
to elements a, b, c and d.
And over here we have a quadword
containing data corresponding
to elements one,
two, three, and four.
With some SIMD
operations we can kind of
figure out the
pairwise interaction
between objects a and
one, between b and two,
c and three and d and four.
But of course we have to be
able to find the interactions
between any pair.
It's not just these
pairs that lineup.
So what we have to do is rotate
the quadword over by one word
and then do the
same thing again.
We do that four times in all
and then we add up the results.
So as you can see
this implementation
is a little bit more
involved and less--
it maps to the original
implementation less directly.
On the other hand, it does give
us a really dramatic speedup.
Because we're using more
of the vector words.
Notice that in the
first packing we had.
We had x, y and z and then
the fourth blank was unused.
Anyway, this time the structure
of a race implementation is
actually 7 1/2 times faster
than the array of structures
implementation.
So choosing this
data layout correctly
can actually be one of the
really big determinants
of how your program performs.
AUDIENCE: The scalar version
was like what 480, something
like that?
Or is it not comparable?
PROFESSOR: I let's see,
David, do you remember?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK so--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: No that
was just on the PPU.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: OK, so
something like 400
for the double buffered one
and 300 for array of structs.
OK one other thing
to worry about
is when you're dealing
with these-- when you're
dealing with these
SIMD instructions,
you want to make sure that all
your data are aligned correctly
in memory.
And like I said before,
when you're pulling things
in from memory you
want to make sure
that whatever you're
pulling in is going to be
aligned on a quadword boundary.
And you can use the
align compiler directive
to tell the compiler,
I want this piece
of data aligned at
a particular place.
And if you do that on all
your arrays for example,
and make sure that your
array-- the array elements
are going to fit
neatly into quadwords
then you should be OK.
Again like I said
before, you also
want to transfer only
multiples of 16-bytes
on the load and store.
And so when you're doing
processing it may help,
it may help you if you actually
pad the end of your-- pad
the end of your array's
so that they fill out
a multiple of 16-bytes.
Because it's easier to just do
that processing with the SIMD
instruction rather
than just have
one or two elements hanging off
and have to worry about those.
AUDIENCE: Question.
PROFESSOR: Yep.
AUDIENCE: Is it a good idea to
pass parameters 2.2 [INAUDIBLE]
I mean, which one is preferred?
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: So you
should [INAUDIBLE]
for figuring out
whether something
can scale easily or not.
So you might make [INAUDIBLE].
So in cases where you
can avoid using pointers,
you should do that.
PROFESSOR: OK.
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
PROFESSOR: So one last
thing that I should mention.
I haven't really let on,
but compilers can actually
generate some of these SIMD
instructions by themselves.
If you declare your types to
be vector and then use just
regular operations
apparently GCC and XLC yes,
will substitute the
correct intrinsics for you.
Of course that doesn't get
you all the operations which
are available with
intrinsics, but anyway
automatically
simbianizing your code
is something that's
really worth looking into.
As we saw it can give you a
great performance improvement.
And the thing is that
compilers are still not
very good at automatically
doing this transformation.
So unlike instruction scheduling
where if your passing 05
your compiler will do a much
better job than you would have
time to do.
This is something that
you should probably
reserve some time for.
That's all.
If you have any questions
you can stick around
and I'll try and help you.